[Musique]
avec 115 médaille olympique 41 titres
c'est le sport le plus médaillé en
france les scream discipline que l'on
peut débuter très jeunes pour en savoir
un peu plus on retrouve mélanie poké sur
ce plateau qui revient avec sa chronique
dédiée au sport pour les plus jeunes
bonsoir mélanie on s'en moque et alors
pour les plus jeunes bien sûr mais
j'imagine que ça intéresse beaucoup
avoué le michael vous avez déjà imité
les duels peut-être passer des jo mais
j'imagine que les quatre mousquetaires
ils ont le droit mais je jouais aux
quatre mousquetaires avec mes voisins je
lave ou alors bien sûr comme tout sport
si on commet jeunes c'est encore mieux à
saint germain en laye ont fait de
l'éveil aux sports c'est destiné aux
enfants à partir de 4 ans avec des
ateliers adaptés bien sûr et du matériel
adapté ce ne sont pas de vraies armes
alors il ya une première phase avec un
échauffement il ya ensuite une phase de
jeu pour maîtriser les déplacements
typique de l'escrim c'est ce qu'on voit
à l'image du franchissement d'obstacles
du maniement de matériel avec des
échelles de rythme des cerceaux dr
franchir
et après ils ont une partie escrime donc
de combat et une petite un tout petit
tout petit partie technique où on va
essayer semaine après semaine
d'apprendre les bases vraiment les
fondamentaux de l'activité
l'objectif c'est de développer des
qualités sportives de coordination
déquilibre de découvrir le matériel et
les premières phases de combat par le
jeu dans les scream il ya trois armes
est ce qu'ils apprennent rapidement
alors il est après là c'est vite mais
pas chez les tout-petits puisqu'il
débute avec le fleuret avec cette arme
on cherche à piquer son adversaire sur
une surface défini il découvre aussi le
salon ce sont deux armes éducative pas
des pc trop lourd encore pour eux et je
vous propose d'écouter ce que les
participants m
les fonds qu ai je un croque des
techniques les marges des scream alors
ils vont aussi découvrir les règles de
courtoisie respecter son adversaire le
saluer avant et après chaque combat les
cordes escrime avec la compétition avec
plutôt vers 9 ans et pour les plus
petits ça se passe en petits groupes
entre 10 et 14 ans quatorze enfants
parmi eux on trouvera peut-être la
future grille ap laura flessel et
pourquoi pas jean françois lamour
merci beaucoup à mélanie pour cette
chronique on vous retrouve bientôt pour
votre chronique junior